can't push safely now
this square's covered twice and the same
for this pawn so it's very hard for
white to make progress he's dropped his
bishop back to one of my favorite
squares for this bishop um just because
it's nice and safe but it doesn't
actually do anything here the grizzchuck
square the gristrok square yeah why is
it called that i remember watching a
great game i got my you know i was
cheering it was david howe for the white
pieces against grizzchuk
and uh david had a very good win by
playing this similar idea
in the iron man competition it's funny
in that tournament i won three games
with white by putting my bishop on this
square
ah interesting
i think it's just coincidence they
weren't necessarily great moves putting
the bishop here but it keeps the bishop
nice and safe for later and we might be
about to see
i know whenever ivanka makes that noise
she thinks it's going to be a draw uh we
might be about to see the white picture
i have to watch out for if i play you
what was it again yeah let's go back to
the players we are about to see a result
the players are repeating the moves and
there we go abrupt but nothing to do the
players repeat aha so